[Applause]
right what a great audience and so many
young faces this is what I came for to
visit you who represent the future
science this is not my first trip to
China it's my first trip to this part of
China but I've been coming here over the
years my first trip was to Beijing to
the National Institutes of life sciences
and I made the mistake of bringing my
twelve-year-old daughter with me and I
say it was a mistake because she so
loved her visit to China that she wound
up spending three years here far from
home but very very much enjoyed spending
three years in Beijing a year at Jing
hua University so she was very pleased
when she heard I was coming back to
China for a visit so as has been said I
hope to tell you a little bit about what
we've learned about the genetic control
of circadian rhythmicity and its
intersections with sleep and many other
physiological properties I'll just start
by pointing out that circadian rhythms
are evidence for circadian rhythms are
all around us
you just have to keep your eyes open we
have a place out in New Mexico the
southwest of the United States which is
a desert environment Canyonlands and
lots of red sand and these little plants
are very happy in our backyard and my
wife and I often go on hikes in the
afternoon when it cools down and I saw
these little the this little plant on
one of our walks a few summers ago the
plants called mirabilis it's also called
its common name is the Colorado four
o'clock and I think you can see where it
gets its name from I snapped a picture
of the plant at 2:00 p.m. on our way
going out on our hike
and when we came back at 6 p.m. I
snapped this picture now the two
pictures are the same plant you can see
this little stick here so there's no
tricks going on it's the same plant but
of course it's in very different form at
2 p.m. and 6 p.m. all the blooms are are
tightly closed at 2 p.m. the plant
looking very sad but at 6 p.m. it's in
full bloom ready for pollination so one
of the things we know about this plant
is that it's pollinated by a hawk moth
which is a nocturnal insect and this is
a desert environment water is precious
in order to open these petals the petals
that form this these flowers water has
to be pumped out of the rest of the
plant and into the petals and of course
once once water leaves the rest of the
plant and is put into the petals
transpiration will reduce the level of
water in the plant so this is a costly
thing for the plant to do so we think
that the reason for this rhythm of bloom
opening and closing has to do with the
preservation esses airy preservation of
water when possible but also making the
blooms available to that nocturnal moth
when the ma nocturnal when the moth is
active
why keep your petals open if there's no
chance of being pollinated in the middle
of the day in the hottest parts of the
day so that the blooms are open all
night long and then close up again in
the morning so this is an example in a
plant of the utility of these biological
clocks as I said they're all around us
in there are more subtle forms of these
rhythms that we can appreciate some of
you may know the work of Karl von Frisch
who received a Nobel Prize for his work
on behavior and particularly in his work
on the communication that dance
languages of honeybees he spent several
decades studying the behavior of bees in
the early part of the night
hundreds and published a book of his
work in 1967 where he described two
different forms of communication about
the location and distance of food that
is produced by foraging bees when they
come back to the hive now what you have
to realize about a beehive in nature is
that the hive encloses a darkened inner
chamber which contains the comb which is
where the honey is stored in the the
larvae and the foraging bees and those
following the foraging bees use that as
their dance form so it's a vertical
dance for in this darkened environment
and von Frisch recognized two forms of
this dance one is just called the round
dance which if you follow these ant
arrows goes something like this and and
this is a is a dance that von Frisch
found means to the to the following bees
there's food close by the hive I'm not
going to tell you too much about which
direction to go in it's easy to find
just just leave the hive and look close
by a more complicated and informative
dance however is something called the
waggle dance which goes through this
sort of a figure-eight configuration and
in this dance the the forger who's come
in from the field produces this figure
eight and every time it crosses the
middle of the figure eight it vibrates
it's its wings and wags its abdomen and
the time it takes to cross the central
part of this figure eight is an
indication of the distance to the food
now in addition the orientation of this
figure eight dance indicates the
direction of the food and so I can show
you a very quick film that shows such a
dancing bee here's the here's the and
here's the teacher going through this
waggle dance you can see them vibrating
is abdomen and as well
her abdomen and her wings and if you
notice the direction of the crossing of
the figure eight you notice that it's
off in a direction like so on that
vertical dance floor now as I said the
orientation of this dance indicates the
direction but it indicates the direction
in terms of the Sun so if the food
source is in a direct line with the Sun
as it sits above the horizon then the
dance will have this configuration where
the the the be the dancing B is moving
vertically at the crossover points in
the film that I showed you notice that
the B was was moving off in this
direction about a 40 degree angle from
vertical and that's an indication that
the food source is about 40 degrees off
from the position of the Sun again with
the distance being indicated by the time
taken to make that crossover now what
especially fascinated von Frisch what
fascinates me is that these dances can
go on for hours inside that darkened
hive and that forager the initial
forager doesn't go back out outside the
hive and recheck the location of the Sun
instead what happens is over time the
forager slightly changes the orientation
of its dance in such a way that over the
several hour period it accurately
predicts the new location of the Sun so
it's giving a modified indication of the
location of the food but always
maintaining accuracy with the current
position of the Sun relative to the food
we now know from work in monarch
butterflies done by Steve reffered at
the University of Massachusetts there's
a great migrations of these butterflies
from North America into Central America
uses a similar Sun compass
time-compensated sun compass and the
little clocks that are used to do this
timing are found in the antennae
and that's been proven by just simply
painting the antenna black in which case
the animals become disoriented and cano
longer migrate they get lost along the
way I'm more more familiar and much more
like our own sleep-wake rhythm is the
our activity rhythms and model mammals
like used in experimental work such as
rodents in this experiment done by Pat
de Courcey and published in the 1960
Cold Spring Harbor symposium which was
owned by biological clocks that year she
looked at the activity and rest behavior
of a single animal over 25 days and the
animal is in a cage in tark constant
darkness for the entire period and
during that period each each of these
lines records the animals activity or
inactivity over the course of the day so
activity is indicated by turning of a
running wheel that's the exercise
machine in the cage foods available all
the time but no change in lighting or
any other environmental signaling and
every day the animal or every 24 hour
segment the animal for a portion of that
segment is on this running wheel which
you can see in these dark and forms of
the record the amazing thing about this
record is that after a few days you can
predict within a couple of minutes when
the animal is going to get on the
running wheel and when it's going to get
off of the running wheel and perhaps
even more importantly this record isn't
vertical which means this is not a
24-hour rhythm it's a circadian rhythm
it's about 24 hours but because it's not
exactly 24 hours it can't possibly
represent some environmental an unknown
environmental cycle it almost certainly
was representing an internal pacemaker
of some sort a biological clock that we
now refer to as a circadian clock now in
further work in the 1970s there was an
effort
to locate within the anatomy of the
rodent brain the source of this kind of
behavior and one of the early
experiments has shown here were
metabolic activity by by putting a
radioactive form of glucose in the
animals drinking water and looking at
differential metabolic activity
indicated by the uptake of that glucose
during the day and during the night
pointed to a special region of the
hypothalamus called the suprachiasmatic
nucleus the SCN which was metabolically
very active during the day and much less
active at night as shown here and other
workers went on to do surgical
experiments asking well what happens if
we take this metabolically cycling
tissue and remove it surgically from the
hypothalamus what is the recovering
animal do and what was found was those
animals no longer exhibited the kind of
wake sleep cycle that I just showed you
in the last slide but in a fascinating
extension of that experiment SCN from a
donor animal was transplanted into the
missing part of the hypothalamus of that
surgically treated animal and that
restored rhythms once again indicating
that very clearly this was a locus a
tissue locus that could drive that kind
of activity and must in some way contain
the workings of a biological clock of
course knowing the tissue is not the
same thing as understanding what's going
on in the cells inside that tissue that
can provide that kind of information
so when I was a beginning graduate
student there was an important paper
that was published from Caltech from
Seymour Benzer laboratory in which his
student Ron Konopka described for the
first time mutations in an organism
which would change the activity the
circadian activity of the animals and
what Konopka found were three mutants
one a rhythmic mutant which looked like
an SCM
in a rodent another mutant that had a
periodicity of 19 hours so the cycle
time had been changed from close to 24
to 19 hours and a third with a long
period rhythm of 28 hours and perhaps
the most important feature of this
collection of mutations was that a
preliminary map mapping suggested they
all affected a single functional gene on
the X chromosome of the fly so we have a
gene that can be modified presumably in
one way to give loss-of-function a
rhythmicity in another way in two other
ways though to produce improperly
running clock so this sounds very much
like substituting the gears in a
mechanical mechanical clock so we were
we were very attracted to this very
interested in this in this novel finding
of mutants that would affect circadian
biology now at the time I was working on
a very different problem I was studying
genes in a region of the Drosophila
chromosome on the X chromosome and
there's a drawing of a portion of the
chromosome where I was working this is a
representation of the giant pol teen
chromosomes of Drosophila which many of
you may have seen that are large enough
that under a microscope you can detect
these dark striations that were thought
to be the genes or in some form the
condensed portions of the chromosome
were thought to correspond to genes and
in fact there'd been an effort to
isolate mutations representing every
gene in this chromosome chromosomal and
row interval as I was a graduate student
aside from just being interested in the
phenomena of having mutants that
affected the clock I was especially
interested in this in this report
because the period gene had been loosely
mapped to a location close to where I
was working I was interested in how DNA
and genes were packed into this region
and whether or not we were missing some
functions in the gene count that we were
doing and period was a novel behavior
that we certainly had not screened for
and so I was anxious to understand the
relationship between that gene and those
that I'd been studying and I found that
the gene mapped right in the middle of
the area that I'd been studying so this
was a lucky find I hadn't been studying
circadian clocks up until that point but
with this sitting in my lap I began to
map further the location in this region
of the gene using a series of chromosome
rearrangements that break the chromosome
and therefore allow you to map the
position of the period locus relative to
all the other genes that we'd found in
this region one of these genes one of
these chromosome rearrangements shown
here t14 JC 43 is a chromosomal
translocation it's an exchange between
the X chromosome and the fourth
chromosome and little or no chromosomal
information is missing in this mutant
you've simply taken a chromosome broken
at 2 chromosomes broken them both apart
and then exchanged
the different parts of those two
chromosomes what I recognized was that
while
Kanaka and Ben's original mutants were
point mutations this was this chromosome
rearrangement was itself a period
mutation up until this time we we
thought that there was no phenotype
associated with that chromosomal
translocation but now I realized thanks
to having period mutants to work with
that this gene this this chromosomal
mutation was yet another example of a
clock mutation a circuit circadian clock
mutation that affect the period locus
now this became a very powerful finding
for us because later after I went to
Stanford to do postdoctoral work to
learn the new techniques of recombinant
DNA and molecular cloning and then moved
on to Rockefeller as a
assistant professor and I began to think
about what kinds of biology might I
study with all these new technologies
I remembered the intriguing behavioral
effects of the period mutations and
recognized that I had a weapon here that
I could use to isolate that gene I had
this translocation that broke the gene
and I say that that represents a new
attack on a gene at the time when DNA
sequencing had not really come into
being you could never find a nucleotide
chain change in a walk through several
thousand base pairs of DNA but you could
never miss a change from one chromosome
to another a chromosome breakpoint and
so in 1984 our group and also a group at
Brandeis that involves colleagues
Michael Ross Bosch and Jeff Hall used
that chromosome rearrangement and the
other mapping that I indicated on the
prior slide to locate this gene and to
isolated and to begin for the first time
to study at the molecular level a gene
that seemed to have a deep connection to
circadian rhythmicity and over the first
few years we learned a number of things
one of the big biggest surprises we had
was this gene was expressed in many
places outside the nervous system and of
course we were expecting activity in the
nervous system since these genes were
controlling circadian behavior but we
were quite surprised to see gene
expression outside the nervous system
and I'll say more about that later
another thing that was discovered in the
course of the next few years of work was
that the gene is expressed with the
circadian rhythm so it controls
behavioral rhythmicity but there's a
molecular rhythm of its production in
addition so we thought of this in this
particular experiment we did something
that was a little akin to the original
SCN surgical experiments where you
remove an SCM from one organism and
Transplant an Sen from another to
restore rhythmicity what we did in this
experiment
to prove that we had the gene was to
begin with a mutant that had no period
gene and we took a wild-type period gene
micro injected it into embryos and
restored the behavior the rhythmic
behavior of developing embryos from that
transplant that genetic transplantation
so in a sense we took this from
identifying the anatomy others had
identified the anatomy and now here we
were dealing with a gene that could
confer rhythmicity or a rhythmicity in
the system so we we realized pretty
early on that there were intriguing
features of this gene but we could never
really understand how a clock works from
just investigating a single gene we also
knew that Ron Konopka had screened only
200 strains of flies mutagenize strains
of flies to find his first clock mutant
and so we thought well let's just do
some more genetic screening so we
weren't as lucky as as Ron in fact two
postdocs Amita Sehgal and jeff preiss
had to screen 7,000 strains of flies to
find the second clock gene in this
system now this is a Photoshop version
of what we did unlike the flower picture
that I showed you but this is what a
7,000 bottles
strain screen would look like and what
you really have to give credit to Jeff
and to Amita for doing as every every
one of these bottles had to be assayed
multiple times over several days every
four hours flies are dumped out of every
bottle counted and you come back in four
hours and do that again and you also
have to do this at during the daytime
and you have to do it all through the
night and you have to do that for
multiple jday so you can imagine the
labor that goes into finding a new
mutant in this way but they did find a
mutant which we named timeless that
turned out to be
exciting and an indication that we were
on the right track using genetics to
figure out the biology of circadian
rhythmicity because the second gene that
we found timeless turned out to be a
partner a physical partner for the
period gene and for the period protein
and this was this was it was especially
significant that they had that these two
genes had that partnership because we
were not doing a genetic screen for
molecules for genes and proteins that
interacted with the first gene period we
were simply asking the animal to tell us
if anything else in its system could
cause an aberrant circadian rhythm and
when we asked that question and found a
new gene and that unbiased fashion what
we found was something that was
connected to the first gene which was
our first indication that there might be
a well-integrated single system that was
responsible for producing the molecular
biology of circadian rhythmicity now
this is much too cumbersome a set of
approaches to to continue but we wanted
more genes and so we reverted to a an
electronic version of screening in which
individual flies are placed in
individual tubes about this long and
about the width of a pencil just just a
big enough diameter for a fly to move
back and forth in and turn around in and
each of these tubes is placed in a slot
there's a light emitting diode on one
side of the slot and a photo transistor
on the other so every time the fly would
break that beam we'd get an event on a
vent on a computer that resembled the
deflections that we had on a pen in that
rodent experiment that I showed at the
beginning of the talk so in this
configuration we can work through tens
of thousands of individual flies
individual strains over the course of a
year a much a much needed pace and as a
result we found nine genes that together
explained
how circadian rhythmicity can be
generated at the molecular level in an
intracellular fashion so I'm just going
to go through a very simple scheme
there's I'm gonna talk about six of
those components for simplicity so if
this square represents the entire cell
and everything on this side of this line
representing the nuclear membrane is
nucleus this is the cytoplasm out here
and we have two genes period and
timeless that are coordinate ly
activated by two proteins one is called
clock and the other is called cycle and
that pair of transcription factors
recognizes homologous promoters on
period and timeless and simultaneously
will produce RNA will direct the
synthesis of RNA off of / and Tim those
RNAs are of course translated in the
cytoplasm into period and timeless
proteins and those individual proteins
have no activity on their own they're
also stuck in the cytoplasm on their own
they have no affinity for the nucleus
but if they can be combined if they can
find each other and form a partnership
they physically associate and then that
association prompts transport to the
nucleus where they physically associate
with the transcription factors clock in
cycle and inhibit the activity of clock
in cycle so when period and timeless are
in the nucleus clock in cycle can't work
when / intim are not in the nucleus the
genes are transcribed so the
oscillations come about from a couple of
different features in a day/night cycle
there is a protein called cryptochrome
which is related to bacterial photo
liaises it's a light absorbing novel
photoreceptor which when activated by
light binds to period causes binds the
timeless causes timeless to be modified
and destroyed by the proteosome so that
when the lights are on all day long
cryptochrome will be will be binding to
timeless and causing timeless to degrade
as rapidly as it synthesized from its
RNA on the other hand a period has its
nemesis which is called double time
which is a kinase casein kinase 1 which
will phosphorylate period if that
partnership is formed and market for
degradation also by the proteasome so
period has two alternative partners one
is timeless and one is double time
if period is bound to timeless then it's
protected from this action of double
time but during day time since there is
no timeless there will be no period
either when the Sun Goes Down period and
timeless can finally be assembled
they'll move to nuclei and all night
long they will suppress the action of
clock in cycle but that repression will
be relieved when timeless in the morning
is destroyed by light and then period is
subsequently destroyed by double time so
you can see that this oscillator this
molecular mechanism will oscillate in a
light dark cycle and will follow that
24-hour cycle in constant darkness the
slow accumulation of timeless and period
assures that the partnership between
period and double time occurs first and
leads to a depletion of period in the
early part of the cycle eventually as
levels of timeless start to match the
levels of double time
these period timeless complexes can be
made and after that lag in time that
added addition of time to disciple
period and timeless can move to the
nuclei nucleus and perform cycles even
in constant darkness now this explains
the the central mechanism that produces
these clocks in the fly but of course
this doesn't explain how behavior and
physiology are affected by these clocks
to understand that we had to look at
gene expressions a gene expression
patterns across the genome and these are
old microarray experiments that we did
in 2001 done by Adam Clara Chang and the
lab and what you see here are a hundred
and fifty genes stacked top to bottom
each of which is monitored every four
hours over a six day period and the
green boxes represent low activity the
red boxes represent high activity and
what you see is that in each case the
gene activity is oscillating is
fluctuating between green and red and
those that have highest expression at
dawn or at the top of the graph those
with highest expression at noon are in
here
dusk down here and midnight here and so
forth so that what we have our nearest
neighbors with the most similar patterns
of expression being represented in this
phase diagram so one of the things I
should emphasize is that these stripes
you've got six stripes running across
diagonally across this diagram and we're
not seeing just a swing between two
states a daytime State and a nighttime
state for example in fact every hour of
the day there's a unique combination of
highs and lows among this set of 150
genes and this is by no means all of the
genes in the fly that are regulated by
in this fashion this is just the most
abundant most robustly oscillating group
of 150 genes now in the next slide I
show the same diagram that I just
finished describing but next to it has
shown a diagram taken over three days in
a light dark cycle the stripes are now
gone and that's because we're now
looking at mutants we're looking at
period no mutants timeless a rhythmic
mutants and clock arrhythmias and
there's something important to be
learned here which is that although
these rhythms are clearly an adaptation
that has taken place hundreds of
millions of years ago in response to a
cycling and predictable predictably
cycling environment of light and dark
and temperature changes while that's the
driving force behind the evolution of
biological clock and this and these gene
expression patterns in the absence of
this set of clock genes
none of that environmental signaling can
produce this cycling gene activity it's
essential to have the clockworks now in
order to translate the environmental
signals into biological activity and in
the same way we no longer need the
environmental cycles in order to have
this clock operate the clock will
operate in constant darkness will
produce these these waves of gene
expression even in the absence of
environmental signals so we're a long
way away presumably from the most
primitive clocks in their earliest state
of manifestation now in addition to
these clocks controlling hundreds or
even thousands of gene expression
patterns across across the genome as if
that's not already complex enough these
clocks are found all over the body and
as I mentioned one of the first puzzles
we had when we isolated period was that
we found clusters of cells all over the
fly's body that we're expressing period
we now know from work that was done by
jeff hall and Steve Kay that their
oscillations are little there were small
clocks operating all over the fly in the
wings and the legs and the antennae and
so forth and a good place to think about
these multiple clocks is a mouse which
is also a tremendous model a very
informative model for looking at
circadian biology and what I want to do
is to describe an experiment that shows
us some of the logic that appears to
underlie the multiplicity of clocks that
we find in these organisms we might ask
why do we have clocks in every cell type
why not just have a master clock in the
brain that tells everything else what to
do so in this experiment which was done
in independently in Michel minoccurs lab
and also in olesia blurrs lab many years
ago in both of those labs they took an
animal that was living in a single time
zone we'll call it New York and assess
the molecular features of the clocks in
multiple tissues and what was found is
that there was agreement among those
clocks because this animal
maintained in a light dark cycle and a
feeding cycle that that simulated New
York City but the experiment came when
an alternative arrangement was was
tested which is we keep the animal on
New York time with regard to the
light-dark cycle but now we're going to
give them food only for an hour a day in
a time zone equivalent to what we have
here at this university and so we've got
a 12-hour disagreement between the the
time of feeding and the time of the
light-dark cycle what's going to happen
in the rest of the animal who's
important with regard to these for these
many clocks across the animal and what
was learned was that in both experiments
that the brain was unaffected by this
conflict between food and light the
brain continued to follow lights of this
animal a nocturnal animal continued to
get on its running wheel and run all
night long but it would get up and eat
during the during the hour or so during
the day it would wake up anticipate the
coming of the food eat the food go back
to sleep and then get on its running
wheel all night long and once again
looking at the brain the molecular
clocks in the brain indicated no change
from that of a synchronized animal but
if the lung the liver or skeletal
muscles were viewed chaos was found they
these other peripheral clocks had now
been reset and they had apparently reset
been reset either in direct or indirect
relation to the timing of food so when a
conflict arises that's when you begin to
see the the operation the independence
of these distributed biological clocks
and another another way of thinking
about that is to think about what's
going on in my own body after coming
from New York
just two or three days ago one of the
things that we know is that if I took
this animal this animal up here and put
it in a new time zone if
was in New York and I brought it to
Shanghai let's say that animal would
take about seven days for all of its
clocks to come to agreement once again
the first to change would be the brain
the brain would pretty quickly adapt to
the new within a couple of days would
adapt to the new light-dark cycle and
feeding schedule but the rest of the the
peripheral clocks the clocks and the
other organs would be suspicious of this
change in time and would take up to
seven days to change to the new location
with the with the liver being among the
the slowest to occur and with different
organs proceeding at different paces so
if you think about what's happening
happen to me right now
my liver isn't here yet but if you look
at my skeletal muscles my skin some of
the other peripheral organs they would
probably be somewhere over the Pacific
still waiting to catch up and just about
the time that I turn around and go back
I'll reproduce this in the other
direction now there are many there are
many things to think about when we
realized this distribution of
information across an animal's body but
and also the the plethora of genes that
are affected by these clocks but I'll
just make one point that's of medical
significance and that is just thinking
about what the consequences to
prescribing medication are if so many
genes and their products are oscillating
so this is work produced by John Hogue
Nicias lab a few years ago in which he
looked at the most popular most
important drug drugs and drug targets
that are currently being used in the in
the United States so of the of the 100
best selling drugs in the u.s. John
found that 56 are have as their targets
genes that are oscillating in response
to the circadian clock now among those
56 half of those 56
that are oscillating are targeted by
medicines that have half-lives that are
less than six hours so what that means
is that if the target peaks at 6 p.m.
and you take that drug at 6 a.m.
you've got 25% of the effective dose of
that drug at the time that it's most
needed when the target is present so
very special attention in the future to
this to the movement of these targets
and the half-life's of the half-lives of
these drugs are going to be extremely
important and also in this diagram were
just has just shown that about half of
all of our genes are oscillating at
least somewhere in our bodies and this
is true among drug targets it's also
true among genes now known to be
associated with disease so this is a
very this is a very leading factor to
think about when considering therapies
for a great number of diseases now in
the remaining time I'd like to just talk
about some recent work that we've been
doing not in Drosophila but in humans
because these genes that were found in
Drosophila are also found in US the same
genes essentially orthologs of these the
small gene set that I described we can
rather easily move to questions of the
biology of humans and we've been
interested in a particular sleep
disorder called delayed sleep phase
disorder these are our night owls and
this cartoon drawn by of communications
that Rockefeller sort of gives an idea
the phenotype this is a student staying
up all night long habitually tapping
away on the computer
preparing from the next day but this is
a lifelong syndrome that I'm going to be
talking about these are individuals that
might have behaved that way as a student
but can't help behaving the same way
much later into life so dspd has found
we believe in about
level of about 5% of the US population
so it's quite abundant it's a persistent
delay in the timing of the major sleep
episode and I'll show you example in a
moment and there's individuals come into
the clinic because it's so difficult to
manage that delayed sleep phase so on
the top of this image is a control
subject the control subject is wearing
an activity watch some of you may be
familiar with these it's almost like a
Fitbit or something similar and they're
also asked to keep a log next to the bed
to indicate their bedtime in red with
these red triangles or their wake time
when they get out of bed with these blue
triangles and each of these lines is 48
hours and it's been constructed this way
so that you can see the major interval
during which sleep is occurring in both
of these individuals so in the top a is
a control subject and there's a very
regular pattern in which bedtime is
occurring around 11:30 each night this
subject is getting out of bed at 7:00
7:30 every morning with great regularity
and this agrees very much with the
activity watch if we compare that though
to the dspd subject that'll say much
more about in a moment you see this is a
very erratic record it's difficult
initially to even find out what the
pattern is but if you look here at the
sleep log you will see these red
triangles indicate that sleep onset sore
bed bedtimes are well past midnight in
every case and wait times are coming up
very close to noon in this individual so
this is very sleep this is a very severe
form of dspd
now fortunately the the the proband
which is illustrated here in this
pedigree had several members of the
family that also told us that they had a
similar sleep disorder and were anxious
to participate in our study and we
perform
whole exome sequencing on all the
members of the family shown here and
what we found was that all of these
indicated in in a dark fill carried a
single nucleotide mutation and I'll
describe in a moment fortunately a
cousin over here was wild-type and of
course it's the cousin that has a normal
sleep wake pattern all of these
individuals had aberrant patterns
resembling dspd so that suggested that
that nucleotide change was associated
with thee was the genetic basis for this
disorder it turned out to be a single
nucleotide substitution at the splice
donor site of following exon 11 in this
13 exon gene that encodes cryptochrome 1
in humans and what that predicted was
that there would not be a splice
possible between exons 11 and 12 that in
fact exon 12 would have to search
upstream and splice taxon 10 resulting
in a 24 amino acid deletion in the
resulting protein and in fact we found
that that prediction held when we look
at RNA produced by skin samples from the
individual skin from individual 11 had
two forms of RNA and two forms of
protein that matched the expectation
from that mutation so we clearly had
individual that had mutation in this
gene that was producing a defective
protein further evidence for the altered
function of that protein was produced by
delivering either the wild-type version
of the gene or this new truncated
version of the gene too naive Mouse
cells or human cells in which case we
could measure a half an hour difference
in the period produced in response to
those gene transfers with a longer
period rhythm associated
a slower running clock associated with
the delivery of the new mutant form of
the protein so clearly we're directly
now able to map at the molecular level
of change related to that nucleotide
variation now in mammals there's a
slight change in the way the clock
functions instead of timeless being the
partner for purr and cryptochrome being
a modifier of timeless cryptochrome is
the direct partner for period and
knowing that we now know that
cryptochrome / partnerships interact
with clock and cycle called clock and be
male and mammals to inhibit the
transcriptional machinery so our
question became one of how might this
nucleus protein change in cryptochrome
affect that interaction and affect the
inhibitory properties of the purr cry
complex to approach that we performed
what's called protein Association assays
using or protein binding assays using
immuno precipitation to selectively
bring down to selectively isolate one of
the partners in that large complex so we
tagged the clock protein with
hemagglutinin and used that to pull down
the combination of proteins that would
interact if we added everything else and
either the full-length version of
cryptochrome or this new truncated
version of cryptochrome or a 50/50
combination of the two so you see here's
the input proteins that were provided
and here is the output and I hope what
you can see is that the full-length
version of the protein is much more
weakly recovered than the new modified
version of the protein indicating that
this new version of the protein is much
stickier and in fact preferentially
interacts with the transcriptional
machinery that drives the production of
RNA off of the targets of clock and
cycle or clock and beam out now that
that gave us insights into the molecular
Mecca
but our biggest surprise came from
looking at the frequency of this mutant
allele in the general population
worldwide and these are data from a
large Cambridge database that contains
60,000 a little over 60,000 exomes and
what you see here are the geographic
distribution of populations for which
whole exome data had been obtained and
what you see is that in that 60,000
whole exomes about a half a percent of
the alleles for cry 1 are of this type
that's the allele frequency and of
course this is a dominant mutation so
what's important is the carrier
frequency which is going to be twice of
that so for example in europeans non
finnish europeans that frequency is high
enough that we can predict at about one
in 75 europeans is going to be a carrier
and may therefore be affected with dspd
by virtue of carrying this variant form
of the gene now to test they are to to
test that prediction we began initiated
a collaboration with a group in Turkey
in Ankara at Bilkent University who were
able to identify a number of individuals
that were carriers of this variant form
of the gene and worked back through
their families to give us a total of
about 60 carriers and 16 on carriers
that were related in these pedigrees so
that we could compare with in the same
groups of families the behavior of the
carriers versus the non carriers and
that summarized down here in the lower
right corner where the black circles
represent the non carriers those that
don't carry this variant form of the
gene and the red circles represent
carrier is either either heterozygotes
or homozygotes which were
indistinguishable phenotypically what
you see with the non carriers is that if
we ask what's the middle of the night
what
when are you halfway through your
nighttime sleep they generally fall at
about 4:00 4:30 at night whereas the
carriers have mid sleep points at about
6:30 about two and a half hours later so
there's a very clear difference between
most of the non carriers and most of the
carriers with delays in the sleep
pattern being seen in the carriers but
we also noticed a second phenotype and
we just refer to these as fragmented
sleepers or Nappers they identify their
first nap of many as their major episode
of sleep each evening so this certainly
confirms that carrying this mutation
indicates that dspd is likely to be a
part of your phenotype so let me just
summarize what I've said in studies of a
number of unrelated families the
presence of this variant form of cry
predicted the dspd
so the penetrance and frequency of this
allele suggest that this is a major
contributor to dspd worldwide since the
disease is since the mutation is found
in multiple members of these families
since its inherited we have to assume
that it's not just behavior but every
organ in the in these subjects is going
to have a clock that's running at the
wrong pace we don't know what the
effects on other aspects of physiology
are yet as I pointed out this version of
the protein has enhanced binding to the
transcriptional activators we think it's
a in a strengthened transcriptional
inhibitor and that also would explain
the dominance of this mutation it simply
substitutes for the wild-type version of
the protein and heterozygotes because of
that strengthened interaction and
finally we've shown directly by
transplantation of this single gene that
that's sufficient to change the
periodicity of the circadian clock in
both Mouse and human cells
so in closing let me talk for just a
minute about what's ahead those sequence
database
are now up to a hundred and forty
thousand whole exomes that's a large
enough database to encompass most
heritable human variation associated
with clinical clinically significant
disorders heritable disorders of sleep
so we think there's already enough data
out there to begin to think about what
is in that pool of variants that can be
analyzed to analyze further to tell us
about sleep for most genes the
distribution of polymorphisms is every
three or four nucleotides so if you go
into these databases and look at all the
variants that you can find in genes
affecting involved in circadian
rhythmicity you see a very dense map of
variation to be assessed you have
population specific carrier frequencies
and you also can tell from the nature of
the polymorphisms you can make educated
guesses about which are likely to
produce changes in the running of the
clock and so by using a cell based assay
you can test ideas about particular
variants test their impact on circadian
rhythmicity and also and those that are
more frequent have the opportunity to
study directly the effects on phenotype
in large numbers of human subjects
finally we all know that sleep has been
associated with a variety of metabolic
and psychiatric disorders and a causal
in a casual fashion but what we'd really
like to understand is whether there's a
causal relationship between disordered
sleep and some of these problems but if
we have large numbers of subjects to
work with and we have different families
all of which share a single genetic
variation that affects sleep in a
particular fashion we should be able to
test those same families for other
aspects of health and determine what
other comorbidities might align with
disordered sleep so I think the
opportunities for the future are quite
high let me point out that Alena pot
gaze done
almost all of the molecular biology
associated with this human project we've
had assistance from Scott Campbell and
Patricia Murphy colleagues that helped
us by identifying patients in the US
with the SPD our sleep records where we
had help analyzing those from Anna
Krieger also from wild Cornell Medicine
typhoon oh slack and his student owner
and not are at Bilkent University and
identified for us the Middle Eastern
patients that we studied as I mentioned
but most importantly I'd like to thank
my oldest colleague which is Drosophila
this is where the work began I don't
think we'd have a clue about where to
start on a human project if it hadn't
been from the contributions of my oldest
colleague and thank all of you for your
attention and enthusiasm for the life
sciences going into the future thank you
very much hey Mike thanks very much for
this wonderful talk spanning from the of
securities that make them with your
friends or suffer - all the way - the
reason the human genetic works and we do
have times for the young audience
student to interact with you and any
questions to knowledge I have three
curious the first way is that
I'm not sure if there's some study on
animal circadian from the on this space
station and yeah and do you think it's a
promise direction - like
tailor our security reason in anyways
like genetic editing or other other
methods since NASA and and mask like
those people are initiated some plans
and secondly I'm not sure all those are
cellular circuits Rossum may be
autonomous on but if there are some
significant effects from the macro
environment or the environment of the
individual or the cell and from their
point of view how do you interpret our
results from our experiment or the
validation between different levels like
cellular or animal models or you visual
in vivo or cross species and lastly as
for the DSP D or some sleep disorders
first is that most of the drugs may have
some side effects on the sleep disorder
I'm not sure how your work or your work
and Beyond can help us decipher those
mechanism or just limit eliminate those
those effects and also from your data
you do from the population or data and
use animal tests and also cellular like
fibroblast test but and I don't know how
to do further work like you understand
it those parents those genetic variants
may influence which part of our body
from mostly and how it
get from the it's just touching and it's
manically how it gets from those people
to change our behavior like the sleep
disorder okay so so thanks for all of
those questions I'll try to step through
them you may have to remind me if I if I
forget one of them but you started with
Space Station question what happens if
we shoot somebody into outer space put
them on a space station and let's say
the space station is going around the
earth multiple times per day do we have
to worry about circadian clocks I think
what we what will happen is since we
know we can isolate humans or model
organisms and constant darkness and we
get an endogenous endogenously
programmed rhythm that reflects this
molecular mechanism that the same things
going to happen when we put them on a
space station our bodies are going to
want to maintain something close to 24
hours on a space station you can deal
with that by just controlling it doesn't
matter how many times per day the
station's going around the earth or any
other planet you can you can control the
light-dark cycle and the pattern of
meals and everything and all of these
external signals on the space station by
a clock by my timers and make them agree
with the biological clocks in our body
the the real problem gets takes place
when we actually land somewhere so if we
land on Mars and we have a new
periodicity that we have to deal with
then I suspect initially what we're
going to do is we're you know you're not
going to be walking around on the
Martian landscape you're going to be
encased in some kind of a of a structure
a building with an artificial
environment and although the Sun will
rise and fall at a different cadence on
the outside some days you'll be waking
up because of the light-dark cycle
inside
the structure in which you're living and
the it may be noon outside and on the
next day and either further forgotten
progression of the Sun but what will
matter is the local environment that
you're that you're associated with so I
don't think I think it would be quite
some time before you'd really want to
think about modifying our own rhythms to
fit that on the other hand we know that
the rotation of the earth has changed
over the last three billion years it's
rotating much more slowly than it did
three billion years ago and yet
biological clocks we can see in fossil
records that biological clocks have been
modified over time to follow the slower
and slower turning of the earth so we
used to have eighteen our biological
clocks in the past or organisms used to
have eighteen our biologicals and the
biological clocks in the past where they
now have closer to 24 hour clocks now
you'd also mentioned side effects of
drugs and with all these oscillations
what what can we imagine about the
importance of side effects and
importantly this has been looked at for
example with chemotherapeutic agents
there's a striking impact on side
effects depending on the time of day of
delivery of many chemotherapeutic agents
and this is almost certainly because
many of the side effects are caused
themselves by oscillating components in
our bodies so I think a challenge for
medicine and a challenge for these kinds
of therapies is as with the other kinds
of medicines where the target you want
to hit is oscillating the side effects
you don't want to have or just as
important to avoid and so a careful
analysis of the the molecular cycling of
those side effects is also important to
to examine ok alright so next the
questions son here professor young as we
all know
Marty proteins the eye brushing changes
throughout there I want to know what are
the central teens controlling sleep on
the secularism and Ozzie are the care
now components urine Sicario reason
purpose first processing and does not
cry Prosecco and the like recycle
because these study never sell ever
Sarah use a user sama true the assembly
rules thank you were you asking about
the control of sleep other aspects of
the control of sleep the slides
circadian rhythmicity because there
there really are two components of sleep
there's the regulation of sleep timing
which is a circadian question but
there's also the regulation of sleep
duration there's a sleep homie
aesthetically programmed and in fact
we've been working to isolate mutants
using fruit flies again Drosophila to to
try to isolate mutations that change the
duration of sleep in the animal and so
far our work and and work of others in
this area have identified nine or ten
genes that do this their mutations of
this of these genes severely truncates
leap often on the order of 30 or 40
percent of sleep is lost so that an
animal that would sleep ten hours a day
sleeps maybe six or seven and so we have
those mutants they still have their
circadian clocks or circadian clocks are
still intact but each day they sleep
much less each 24-hour cycle they sleep
much less than their wild type
counterparts and one of the the reasons
that we wanted to take this approach is
because we don't know what sleep is for
there's been much speculation
and I won't repeat the the nature of the
speculation I think we're all aware of
the many hypotheses about the role of
sleep but we thought that if we approach
this genetically and isolate several
genes mutations in several genes where
we have thousands of of of organisms all
of which are genetically identical but
all share this loss of sleep then if we
can find a convergence in effects on
biology then that can help us understand
what sleep is for in a very unbiased
fashion and one of the things that we
found is that there is one aspect of
uniformity and that is all of these
mutants that shorten sleep similar short
similarly shortened lifespan so a loss
of 30 to 35 percent of sleep duration in
a fly will produce about a 50% reduction
in lifespan and that's routine across
the different genes so already we know
that the animals are sicker and what
we're trying to understand now is why
are they sick or why are their they
dying is there or is it a multitude of
problems or is there a centrality and
and we don't know yet but it does
suggest that we should all pay attention
not only did the timing asleep but to
sleep duration if it if it if it's bad
for the fly it's probably bad for us to
miss - miss sleep test - the activities
of each organs in the mass because you
showed a photo that like different
organs so yeah so the way that the way
schibler and menaker did those
experiments was to isolate tissues
isolate tissues at the same time of day
different tissues at the same time of
day or night from and
from animals that have been exposed to
those different environmental paradigms
so the same animal you're testing the
molecular at this site you isolate cells
from the liver you isolate cells from
the brain you isolate cells from the
skeletal muscle from the lung you you
can then so you you you have several
animals that are taking it that where
you're taking tissue samples at
different times of day and you're
looking and you produce an a a map of
the oscillation of the key genes in each
of those tissues over the course of the
24-hour day that way you see what the
lung is doing you see what the liver is
doing you see what the skin is doing and
so forth during a day well so for
example the liver has a robust circadian
rhythm for hundreds in mammals probably
thousands of genes many of which are
associated with metabolize metabolizing
the fuel that comes from meals the
pancreas of course is is regulating
glucose oscillations in glucose one of
the another another feature to point out
is that if we make mutations where we
block the function of the clock in a
single tissue like the pancreas
even though clocks are running properly
everywhere else in the animal that
animal will develop diabetes because it
doesn't have a clock in its pancreas if
you do the same experiment and eliminate
the clock function and liver and have
clock function everywhere else you'll
get a metabolic syndrome in that animal
so so we have many different ways of
looking at the the critical function of
these oscillations in these different
organs and certainly every organs
oscillation have independent effects on
the health of the animal
I think we have more questions but the
next time each one have one question
so give more a chance for individuals
okay just one question from the slide
that is one xxo me aggregation
consortium was the significant
difference between the European non
finish and the finish like I don't
understand what's the difference why why
it does why has like two different rows
European population is separate of
finish and not finish why that oh I see
well this is just this is just so that
you can understand that a particular
allele a variant allele is represented
at a different frequency in different
populations so for example you may have
noticed that East Asians that allele is
very very rare in Europeans it's it's
much more common I think what it
reflects so it's added information from
collect from paying attention to
different populations because it
suggests that that mutation arose
somewhere near Europe and as is high
near the the locus of origin and has
been carried by migration to other parts
of the world but it's a it's additional
information about the way genes travel
from the site of their origin or
particular variation 'z travel from the
site of their origin through other parts
of the world right well I think I think
that's because the finns didn't come
from europe they're from farther east
and so you have you have populations
that have come into too much of europe
from from different locations and now
we're you know with these kinds of
methods you begin to see this so even
though you don't have a written history
to tell you this you can see it from
from the from the genetics it's left
behind so since you mentioned about
there's kind of sleep disorder that is
the shorten not the sleep duration so I
wonder this dspd mmm because from the
actogram and I didn't notice that have a
shortened the sleep duration so whether
this is a for what a reason it is called
a sleep disorder for this dspd phenotype
so this is the first question and second
one is in this a human gene mutation
that are related to the dspd so we know
that circadian rhythm and sleep-wake
cycle are covered so whether this
phenotype is due to the lensing of the
period or due to the effect on the
sleep/wake cycle so this is so I'll deal
with a second question first which is
you know we clearly have a mutation in a
gene that we understand has a role in
producing the circadian clock and the
nature of that mutation from our cell
cell to cell transplant of the gene
shows us that that gene will change the
period of that molecular cycle and
therefore the rhythmicity of all the
gene expression that goes on in cells
that are directed by that form of the
clock so there's a it's it's it's well
known in human biology by studies that
have compared individuals with varied
periods where the the origins of the
differences in period are unknown that
different different that that period
differences that lengthened period from
from average tend to delay phase of the
sleep/wake cycle and those that tend to
shorten period from the
tend to produce morning mists and
there's a fairly simple quantitative
relationship which is that for every
hour change in period you get about a
five hour change in phase whether it's
an advance or a sleep delay so so it's
quite it's quite consistent with with
what's known in Prior human data to
think that a half an hour change in
period will produce a sleep-wake cycle
change of of two and a half hours so the
we would tend to think that this is a
circadian change that you're driving the
pattern of sleep-wake cycle rather than
vice-versa because we found the variant
I think the another question was why do
we call this a sleep disorder and there
are two possible answers to that it
should be called a sleep wake disorder
because we're talking about a sleep
timing issue which is independent of how
long you sleep each each night and in
fact we're not really finding a big
change in sleep duration as a result of
this but we are finding a sleep wake
disorder as I as I've described that
being said if if you're an individual
that has a job that begins that at noon
and ends at 2 o'clock in the morning
you're probably very fit for that and so
even the notion of calling it is
disorder is just something that's a part
of the medical literature as opposed to
really judging that an individual in a
given environment is necessarily going
to see this as a problem most of us
unfortunately have job requirements that
that conflict with that kind of a
pattern now
Thank You professor I have two simple
questions the first one in the beginning
of this talking you you say in tenth we
have different angles to influence is
gross so if this crouching influence
this and
gross or not yeah my missing part of
your question so you're asking about the
clock genes in plants yes so if if you
if you examine the the specific clock
genes in plants this has been done for
example using a rabbit OPS's in a
considerable detail you find a mechanism
that looks a lot like what are described
in animals but there are different
proteins and different genes the the
strategy is much the same where you have
activators and inhibitors and and a
transcription based clock where you're
switching genes on and switching genes
off with a circadian rhythm but the the
specifics of the genes and proteins
involved they're unrecognizable from the
animal kingdom but throughout the animal
kingdom you have genes and proteins that
look very much the same whether you're
talking about Drosophila so it's one
questions as I mentioned okay alright
you can stop here thank you
you have one question every gene is the
tissue specific so if the genes which
are related to the sleep disorder then
they should be the express in all the
tissue are in specific tissues of the
body so yeah this is an important point
so the clock this this simple molecular
mechanism winds up regulating different
genes in different tissues always with a
circadian rhythm of one sort or another
but the targets can be different so for
example if you're dealing with a
a set of targets in a in a cell that
responds to say glucocorticoid
glucocorticoid will directly interact
with cryptochrome and produce cyclicals
in gene activity from that combined
receptor that differ from cells that
don't have Bucca corticoid receptor and
we don't we don't have details about how
this happens in almost all the tissues
but what you do see is if you isolate a
given tissue like liver and compare that
to skin for example you see different
genes that are oscillating in those two
tissues in both cases you have to have a
clock to get those oscillations and in
both cases the oscillation the clocks
look the same so the same clock
mechanism is somehow able to drive
different sets of genes in a cell
type-specific fashion so this is a
problem for developmental biology
ultimately and it's it's one of the the
remaining frontiers in this area okay so
I take the transport the last questions
it's the only privilege I have okay so
well we we know that this evolution is
secularism mechanism controlled very
robustly 24-hour clock 24-hour cycle and
we know that all these depend on the
inter patients and all these proteins
level transcription levels how this
robust is coming from I just wonder
because you keep into the darkness
without any cue these still running very
robustly in this cycle it not because of
or the molecular Magnum itself is a very
robust always it because of the aku
could be himself together the bee case
together with now the single cell
sequencing signal imaging method can be
also is question now ya know it's a it's
a it's a great point and in fact if you
if you pull cells out of the animal even
though they have the same clocks and
they may be the same tissue originally
you dissociate those cells and they
become they could become more less and
less synchronous as you take them out of
the animal so and eventually after you
after you
an animal in the dark for a very long
time you'll see a dampening of the
rhythm in many cases so I think this is
a problem of synchrony and the primary
so you have an oscillator that is
running at the level is largely so
autonomous there are signals going
between cells that can help them remain
synchronous but the most robust
synchronizer are these environmental
external signals and again this is a
system that is evolved to help us deal
with the outside world and so the the
system has not really been challenged to
run on its own without environmental
signals for long periods of time we can
do it for short periods of time and of
course we've now moved into higher and
higher latitudes where where those
signals are less and less robust and we
do see problems when we when we do that
but yeah I think synchrony synchrony is
is best enforced by robust environmental
signals okay and I would like to thanks
dr. Michael Young and the noble 5 media
and also as news icons for this
wonderful event for our student
faculties and the communities and the
less sex dr. young thanks
[Music]
[Applause]
you